- [Voiceover] Ketchup.
So American, it's basically the red
in red, white, and blue, right?
And that red clearly is from the tomatoes
the ketchup is made from.
- [Voiceover] Yum!
- [Voiceover] But that
wasn't always the case.
The first recorded recipe
for ketchup comes from China.
And for more than a thousand years
it wasn't even made with tomatoes.
It was made with fish guts.
- [Voiceover] Eww!
- [Voiceover] Fish intestines,
bladder, and stomach
all mixed together with salt,
then sealed and heated in the
hot summer sun for 20 days.
That was the original ketchup.
A fermented fish paste that
dates back to 6th century China.
It was popular throughout Southeast Asia
and British and Dutch settlers
who arrived in the 1600s
loved the stuff.
Over time, they brought
ketchup home to Europe
and added their own modifications
including beer, mushrooms, walnuts,
oysters, strawberries and peaches.
By the mid-1700s, English
ketchup was a mainstay
on British dinner tables
and as colonists went west,
it soon made its way across the pond.
That's where tomatoes come in.
They're native to the Americas.
And it's rumored Europeans once
believed they were poisonous
but poisonous, they were not.
In 1812, a Philadelphia
horticulturalist and scientist
by the name of James Mease
introduced tomatoes into the mix.
He published a tomato ketchup recipe
that was the beginning
of a new crimson era.
From there, many different
iterations were concocted
and by the end of the 18th century,
The New York Tribune called tomato ketchup
America's national condiment
that was on every table in the land.
Which brings us back to this.
Tomato ketchup is here to stay.
- And I, for one,
don't miss the fish guts.
(lighthearted music)